[Music]
at first glance it looks like a normal
hamburger but it's not just any old
burger because half of the meat patty
consists of ground-up insect larvae
student baraboo cumin tried out the
Bucks burger I think it's my friends the
main ingredient in Vera's box burger is
ground blesser mealworms the larvae of
the darkling beetle the production of
the insect burgers begins here in the
Dutch town of air below the
manufacturers have been breeding insects
here for about forty years mainly as
animal feed and for the cosmetics
industry but recently they've been
producing more and more larvae for human
consumption Nicol Ruud is plant manager
of Proteas arm he performs regular
checks on the quality of his worms
around two billion people around the
world eat insects daily but it's still a
big taboo in Europe I think within five
years it's quite normal to eat insects
it'll be inside as an ingredient in a
lot of food products I think so within
five years I think we all it's a couple
of times a year insects the worms are a
sustainable source of energy containing
50% protein they only need a fraction of
the space water and feed that breeding
higher orders of animals requires and
their co2 emissions are minimal the
larvae live for three months in these
boxes where they consume grain when
they're large enough to be harvested
they're flash frozen and shipped to
customers max Kramer and bearish ersal
are the founders of Buck's burger they
started their company bug foundation in
2014 with 10,000 euros in start-up
capital now the young entrepreneurs
employ a team of four people
the founders first encountered edible
insects during a world trip seven years
ago that's how they got the idea to
start their business when we first told
friends family and acquaintances about
our idea most of them said we were crazy
that there's no way it would work in the
meantime everybody thinks what we're
doing is cool and the next thing they
say is hey when can we finally try it
out they worked on the development of
their burger patties for more than a
year the ground mealworms are mixed with
peas water and a secret spice mixture
the founders hope their burger will lead
to less meat being eaten that will be
good for the environment because less
grain will be used for cattle feed and
the insects are also climate friendly at
the same time we're hoping will become a
model for other countries for instance
in developing countries where they used
to eat insects but stop doing so in
order to adopt the western lifestyle and
eat beef burgers following the
McDonald's lifestyle in Germany it's
still illegal to sell food products
containing insects but a few restaurants
in Belgium and the Netherlands already
have Bucks burgers on their menus the
exotic hamburgers cost between 12 and 17
euros starting next year selling insect
food products will be legalized in
Germany - then the bug foundation
founders will be worming their way into
the fast food business
[Music]